يقول الناس إنني مجنون كان ستان نيكولاس
مؤديًا بالفطرة
[موسيقى]
ومؤسس فرقة ريفر باند المحترقة ومقرها كليفلاند، وقد
أمضى عقودًا على خشبة المسرح ولكن كل ذلك
توقف في إحدى الأمسيات في عام 2017.
كان عمره 66 عامًا، لقد
فقدت حياتي  كنت أتوازن وأسقط على
الأرض في كل مرة وصلت فيها إلى منتصف الطريق،
كانت ركبتي تنحني وأسقط
مرة أخرى.
وبعد 14 ساعة، دخل أحد الأصدقاء إلى
منزله ووجده على الأرض، وتم
نقلي إلى مستشفى جامعي في
وسط مدينة كليفلاند حيث  استيقظت وكان هناك
طبيب يقف فوقي، سألت
الطبيب إذا كنت قد مت،
قال الطبيب إنك تعرضت لسكتة
دماغية سيئة، هذا هو شكل دماغ ستان
بعد بضعة أيام، كل ذلك الجزء المظلم على
اليسار، وهو الجزء من دماغ ستان
الذي  توفيت لأنه لم يتلق ما
يكفي من الدم، لذا لم أتمكن من المشي عندما
استيقظت،
لم أتمكن من تحريك ذراعي اليسرى أو يدي اليسرى،
اعتقدت أنني سأظل
معاقة مدى الحياة،
ولقد عانيت كثيرًا  العلاج
في غضون بضعة أشهر، كل ما كان ستان
قادرًا على فعله هو اتخاذ بضع خطوات
ثم استقر ببساطة
عندما رأيته لأول مرة، ما هو
توقع تعافيه،
كانت التوقعات سيئة،
فقد مر أكثر من عام على
السكتة الدماغية التي أصيب بها  خضع بالفعل
للعلاج الطبيعي، وعلى الرغم من
التحسن المبكر الذي طرأ على حالته، إلا أنه
لم يتحسن بعد الآن،
ولهذا السبب قدم الدكتور أندريه ماتشادو،
جراح الأعصاب في كليفلاند كلينك،
شيئًا لستان كان
الأول من نوعه في البشر، وهو
محفز عميق للدماغ، وهذا ما
تراه هناك.
ربما تكون قد سمعت الآن عن هذه الأدوية الخاصة
بمرض باركنسون ولكن تم
وضعها خصيصًا لمساعدة ستان على التعافي
من سكتة دماغية
كان ستان يعاني من الضعف ولكنه كان قادرًا على المشي
برجله اليسرى ولكنها كانت في الواقع
ذراعه ولم يتمكن من إغلاقها
وفتحها  يده ورفع ذراعه كان
يواجه صعوبات، كان يواجه
الصعوبات العادية في استخدام يده لأي
نشاط مفيد للحياة اليومية على
الجانب الأيسر،
لذلك في سبتمبر من عام 2020، بعد ثلاث سنوات من
إصابته بالسكتة الدماغية، خضع ستان لعملية
جراحية استمرت ثماني ساعات حيث كان هذا  تم وضع
مسبار بحجم 1.3 ملم وهو
بعرض حبة رمل في
المخيخ في دماغه، وتم
وضع محفز للعلاج الطبيعي بعد فترة وجيزة من
بدء رؤية أي تغييرات خلال
الشهر الأول، يمكنني رفع ذراعي اليسرى
وهو ما لم أستطع.  لا تنظر إلى هذا،
يمكن أن يتحول هذا من الأمل
الذي هو عليه اليوم إلى علاج ربما
يكون علاجًا قياسيًا في المستقبل
لستان، فهو يعني الآن القدرة على العيش
بشكل مستقل
فقط ساعدني في طهي الطعام وتحمل
وجباتي وتناول الطعام
والأشياء المحيطة
بفناء المنزل والأعمال
المنزلية،
وآمل أن يتمكن في يوم من الأيام من
اللعب مرة أخرى،
تقرير الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا لشبكة سي إن إن
[موسيقى]